where will you put your oscar in your
home
because your speech was so moving what
did you think about will smith's speech
uh where will i put my oscar my home i
have no
idea uh
i don't know i feel really i still can't
understand that i'm holding on this is
the first time i've held an oscar i'm
fred's with eddie redmayne and i've been
to his house
in london and i was everyone was like oh
look his oscar and they all picked it up
and i was like i can't pick it up like i
felt superstitious so this is the very
first time i've even held it so i have
had no thought of where it's going to go
but i will respect it for sure wherever
it is thank you
um what does this win mean to you
uh it's very meaningful to me it was ten
years ago uh that i got the rights to
tell this story and
i think that was the first year i was
nominated for an oscar and it was the
first year i you know i had seven films
come out in 2011 and so to be at the
awards ceremony in 2012 uh was the
beginning of my career
and to be here 10 years later with a
film that i bought the rights to
that i kind of
willed into existence
is incredibly meaningful
also it's very special
to be part of a film
that
that means something to me in that it
writes a misjustice you know it
re-examines a life
it's so important to give each other our
flowers when we're still alive and i
feel like we miss that opportunity with
tammy fay
so it's very special to me i was texting
with her children during the ceremony i
kept texting them
it's a beautiful beautiful moment and
it means so much to me in terms of my
profession but also in terms of my life
and
what i'm putting out into the world
thank you and now we're going to our
virtual press room la weekly asia
hi jessica congratulations thank you
this is daniel from alawiki asia from
taiwan um i just want i have a fun one
for you and that's a lot of people on
twitter are saying that you are the
fifth actress in the help to help you in
an oscar is that film like some kind of
lucky charm for you and do you not have
like an oscars club
i i think that's actually a testament to
tate taylor and his incredible
skills at
casting and you know he fought for me to
be in the help um he really
i definitely wasn't the obvious choice
for the part of celia foote i didn't
look like her i didn't sound like her
and he fought for me for that role and
it really goes to show
his respect and his admiration for
actresses and i think you can see that
in
the careers that the the
women have had since his film i mean
when you look back at what we made and
put out in 2011 many of us were at the
very very beginning of our uh careers
and so
yeah i i thank tate taylor for that
incredible thank you congratulations
thank you thank you thank you
is that it
that was easy
okay
bye guys
you